I would like to warmly welcome you to Hannah
Arendt. She is rightly considered the
most important philosopher in the world and
no other thinker and, incidentally,
no other thinker has
experienced totalitarianism so closely and at
the same time analyzed it so precisely and brilliantly
as Hannah Arendt. She is
an outstanding intellectual
but  You will also see that today, an
incorruptible person, a
citizen of the world who defended her views when she
thinks they are,
unconditionally and radically,
even against the greatest resistance
In
America then in Germany then
known worldwide I is called Elements and
Origins of Total Domination
and this main work is directly
linked to her biography. She was born in
Königsberg as a German citizen, the
child of Jewish parents
but the mother was a Protestant Protestant
but ultimately they were a
non-religious one  In
Arendt's upbringing, religion played no role.
She went to high school at the age of 14 and had
already read Immanuel Kant. I ca
n't even think about what I
did when I was fourteen and she
decided to study philosophy and
did that at the age of 18 in
Marburg  With Martin Heidegger, with whom she
fell in love and with whom she then
had a passionate affair.
Heidecker later said Hannah
Arendt was the great passion of his
life. She then worked at the FAZ
as a journalist and
then had to experience how her homeland fell into
dictatorship  Liked she saw how
the National Socialists got more and more
votes and were actually
able to appoint the chancellor in 1933 and
she said the bad thing for her
was not just the political development
but above all the development around
what was happening in the circle of people she knew
was
the problem that was personal  The problem was
n't what our enemies did,
but what our friends did. Yes, and
you have to keep in mind that Martin Heidegger,
I think, admired and loved. He
actually joined the Nazi Party in 1933,
but
also in Königsberg, more and more people gradually came into
contact with it
Jews and Jewish families were shunned
and she also felt very intensely
that it was as if an empty space was
forming around you and she was then
arrested and interrogated by the Gestapo but
released again and therefore fled to France a lot
When
the war broke out when Hitler invaded France,
she was
taken to an internment camp there and was able to
escape again to Portugal and
then came by ship to the
United States via Lisbon and from
there in exile she actually
saw how the war continued
What we saw
was another milestone when she found out
that there actually were extermination camps
and at first she didn't want to believe it,
but the evidence became clearer and
clearer and she could no longer
suppress it and she says, quote, it was
really as if the abyss was opening up
So you have to ask yourself why am I telling
you the biographical details here?
First you have to imagine what it
must have been like for her. She was
enthusiastic about German idealism, a
fan of those in love with the Chancellor. Martin
Heidegger was a German journalist and
then something like that, so that her homeland was her
country  The poet and thinker, as she once
said, goes to a place next to
one of the greatest mass murderers in
history. That has to be
put aside first and she didn't, as would have
been expected, fall into resignation
or total bitterness. No,
she said now it's okay  It's about
us understanding it, only then can we
learn from it. Yes, it's important that we
look closely now and that's when she
said her famous sentence,
which became her motto in life. I want to
understand and that's what we're concerned with today.
We want to understand as in  Italy
in Spain in Germany in Russia
dictatorships came to power
fascist regimes
dictatorial or created
Stalinism arose which ultimately
culminated in gulags and
concentration camps and Hannah Arendt
gives the answer to how this
arose on the one hand in her
totalitarianism book on the other hand
also and here we come to it in the
book Eichmann in Jerusalem a report
on the banality of evil and this
book caused a furor and is still being
discussed passionately in a very differentiated way to this day well
and it starts in the totalitarianism
book she starts by saying yes  Well,
how did the whole thing come about? Elements
and origins of total domination and she
says what makes modern people so easily
caught up in totalitarian movements is the
increasing abandonment everywhere.
With abandonment, she means that
modern people
are no longer safe in the
extended family and no longer
identify with their own  Work as a
craftsman makes things where he
puts his seal on it - it's no longer in the
guild in the guild - he's no
longer anchored in his church community,
whether it's Catholic or Protestant,
but rather he's a modern man and
he's played a key role in shaping his concept  lives in
mass society and he feels
interchangeable. He feels
interchangeable and replaced at any time. He no
longer has any individuality, yes, and that is the
feeling of abandonment and she says
a feeling that is completely new in Europe
and has only emerged from the
extraordinary increase in population  In
the last 150 years, and
in fact we can
hardly imagine it today, there was
enormous
population protection at the beginning of the
twentieth century. Between
1750 and 1910 alone, the population in
the territory of the German Empire
increased from 6 million to 65 million, i.e. more than
increased tenfold in a historically relatively
short period of time and
sprouted huge metropolises from the ground, an
insane urbanization that was the
beginning of mass society
and Hannah Arendt says the mass of
desperate and
resentful individuals grew very quickly
after the First World War in Germany
and Austria where inflation and
unemployment  The
military defeat
followed in short intervals and this led to
unemployment. People knew that they
could be fired at any time or could not
find a job. They were not
needed and those who worked
were afraid to favor themselves and
lose their jobs. Everyone
could be replaced. There were many
day laborers
led to the fact that people
could no longer find their meaning in life anywhere, at least not
from their professional activities,
religious involvement also
declined more and more and all of that,
mass society, the loss was
the ideal breeding ground for ideologies
for totalitarian ideologies and
the ideology be it  From Steinism
or communism or from
National Socialism, people
suddenly had a kind of meaning
in life, a kind of stability in life. So, for
example,
Hitler promised people a great
Germanic empire,
building which everyone is valuable and everyone can
become. In communism,
people were promised  A workers' paradise
promised a workers and farmers
state and a classless society
and this historical structure yes, that
is a generic term mandate in which
every single person has to participate. Suddenly
life was made meaningful again
but says Anna Ring the problem with
these ideologies was that you can be
has given up his own thinking and we
also have a nice quote from your
husband. You could probably say that the
living humanity of a person
decreases to the extent that he gives up
thinking, but people have
given up thinking and
suddenly they were no longer up
themselves, but rather the meaning of life
was explained to them. For example,
in place of individualistically
understood human dignity, in
ethnic thinking there was the idea that
everyone who was born the same people
is connected to one another in a completely natural way and that is
actually an ideology that only
if  you are born into the same people
that you are then connected like a family,
that didn't exist before,
the bourgeoisie was world bourgeois but
suddenly this individuality was
and are actually called communism
and national socialism,
both ideologies give a total
explanation of the  world therefore totalitarianism
the entire history is explained
the goal and the course of
history are determined in
National Socialism it was, so to speak, the
natural separation of the
races which culminates in the Germanic
master race which then dominates all others
as the goal of
history in communism it was one
of the  history predetermined sequence
of class struggles that ends, so to speak, in the
classless socialist
society and the
two ideologies not only
gave people the course and goal of history but also told people
who stands in the way of this goal and, so to speak,
defined the enemies of this natural or historical development
and these  They were enemies, on the
one hand, of course, the inferior
races in National Socialism and
Communism were the dying
classes, i.e. the reactionary
classes that
stand in the way of further history and Hannah Arendt says that
we are serious about the fact that in the struggle of the
classes there are always dying people  classes have
to be given, so it follows that you
always have to eradicate new groups of society. If
you are serious about the fact
that there are parasites in the lives of peoples, it
follows that you
can deal with them in the same way as you would with bugs and
lice, which, as is well known, you eradicate with poison gas
and because  These two ideologies have,
so to speak, clearly defined the enemies of the
process. He says that,
for example, this also had
consequences, whether it was that disabled people
were bad for the national body, or
that inferior races were not
allowed to be married or that they were
later persecuted and
killed  have to be or with Stalin
or
communism, for example, the
traditional ideal class of the nobility was
partially exterminated, the tsar's family
was liquidated because it was a
dying class that had to go and
Stalin of course liquidated everyone who
stood in his way, he also in the
Moscow trials almost the entire
management team of the industry how does the
leaning still governed and fought had
he had it executed so the
ideologies give great
opportunities and are already
making preparation in this is talking
about the preparation of victims and and
if an ideology but first  has
established itself then says they are all
threatened, so to speak, because no one is sure
whether it will not suddenly
be defined as a counter-revolution, he will be defined as
someone who
stands in the way of general development, there are no complaints,
I imagine yes, and that's why she then says
terror is the real thing  essence of total
domination
and evening was very much criticized by the political
left for this book
elements and origins of total
domination because the
political left said
totalitarianism that would just be a new
catchphrase with which you
can simply lump communism and National Socialism together although
But the goals are completely different.
Yes, you know, Max had
in mind ultimately a classless
society and, after the world revolution,
a state in which all peoples
lived peacefully next to each other in a
socialist fraternity. We
of course have National Socialism,
culminating in the rule of one race
that then oppresses all others  So from
that point of view, the goal is actually
different and from that point of view you can
accuse her to some extent of
lumping it together, but she
didn't do it to
defame communism, she was
married to a communist herself, she just wanted to
Let's show that
the same structures are actually implemented by Indians
in the implementation and
of course they were under the impression of the
concentration camps and the gulags that
existed back then and their conclusion is that
totalitarianism captures people in
their totality right down to their private lives
a completely new form there were
also dictatorships in antiquity but
totalitarianism is something completely new that
was only possible in mass society
and your conclusion is that people who adhere to such an
ideology lose their
humanity because they no longer
make decisions for themselves and this danger still exists
today  also for our democracy and
she is now writing a second book where
she says why
people's humanity is at risk when we only
function, so to speak, and allow ourselves to be set goals
and that's what she does in her
philosophical book. Her philosophical
main work is again called more active from
Active life from active life
is called being active again because Hannah
Arendt says well if you
look at people philosophically then you notice
that they are active all their life
and she wants to shed light on what
this activity actually means
and she says that people
do it  his life within three
areas of activity either working
or producing or acting that
describes our whole life work
that is the lowest form of our activity
smit working means see I
quote work corresponds to the
biological process of the human
body which naturally approaches things
which the  Work produces and prepares
it so that is actually very easy to
understand the work corresponds to the
biological process of the human
body what does it mean we are hungry we are thirsty we
need clothes
otherwise we will freeze and this biological
process means that we have to work for it
farmers, for example, work
when  They raise the things so that we
can eat but the housewife also
works. We have to
go shopping. We have to get the food. We
have to cook. We have to wash
That's why the lowest form of
development in being active is working and
yes, I mean, just
imagine how many times we have vacuumed
in our lives or
stood in line at the
supermarket, yes they are recurring
activities as if they were done then it works  for
a while then the
wool mice are there again, so that's why work is
used up so quickly, I know, for them
the lowest development even if it
is necessary, of course, the
next higher form is manufacturing,
I quote, manufacturing produces
an artificial world of things that are created by
the  Living processes are not simply
crushed,
so producing is a higher
form of static science because what we
produce is not immediately
crushed again, for example when we
build a cathedral, thanks to which there is
first or a statue or when we
create art values ​​or even when
hannah  Arendt writes
a book, she produces a book and you can see that these
books here still concern us today,
even though they are no longer there
because everything that is produced
accompanies our lives and endures,
which is why producing is a higher
form of activity, the highest  Form,
however, is acting
I quote acting is the only
activity of the vita activa that takes place directly between people without
the mediation of matter material and
things with
acting what does she mean by acting
what happens directly between
people is what she basically means  In the
sense of Habermas, communicative
action, but she herself refers
to Aristotle and to the bonum
commune and you know Aristotle says
that humans are by nature a
social being. They can only develop with
other people in society
and the highest form of this
development is me  The common concern in
the police for the bonum municipality and
that's why
political action is so important
and Hannah Arendt was but
maybe I can still have a
nice quote.
The people were accordingly open and showed who they were,
actively showing their personalities
Uniqueness of her being in action It is
only in communicative action together
with others in conversation in discourse that
we first develop our authenticity
and that is why she sees action as
the highest form of human
activity. She was
of course criticized for this book
because the women's associations have
Said that would be a complete devaluation
of housework. You have to keep in mind that
currently in the 50s there was
emancipation and not that far.
Few men actively helped in the household
and then it was said that
housework was completely devalued, the work
of the farmers was devalued and you
Her own existence as a writer, the fact that
she writes books and is very political,
is far too overrated, but of
course what you have to see and did
n't write that because now that
she wanted to set up a higher level here, it
wasn't that important that's what it
was about  In a historical
outline also to show that in the ancient
police the action was very highly valued,
the common political action in the
Middle Ages, the people then
made well
every saddler
carved his signature into the saddle, everyone was an
artist, yes the craftsmen were proud,
every blacksmith  has made a mark
so the builders et
cetera have, so to speak, found each other in their production
and in modern times
with us we only work and that
is a loss a big loss that
we live in a working society
but the modern mass society is
a working society it is  looking for
growth she wants everyone to be
busy she wants everyone to
work and whoever only works is,
so to speak, a cog in this big whole
that is completely managed by
the bureaucracy, she also talks about
the rule, there is no one who does
n't
think about it anymore, so to speak  his own
development and the meaning of life
and that is very dangerous when the
working society there is a danger
that people will just function
that they will just function and
no longer
think about living in the community
and as an example of
such a person who always  It only
worked, but it no longer worked at all when a
human being developed, so to speak, and
lived his own humanity.
Now you have Adolf Eichmann here,
by the way, this is your book about it. Your
third major work, I once
brought him with me to Eichmann in Jerusalem, a
report on the banality of this  Book
would be really hotly debated as you will
see in a moment and I
brought you the cover photo here,
I think it's slightly different.
Here you see Eichmann sitting in a
glass box, a policeman on the right and left
and a man was an official, he was the
head of the transport department in the
third  Reich and
he succeeded, he
actually brought an estimated four to six
million Jews by train to the
concentration and extermination camps.
He organized the transport
because he was
in charge of the transport department and he
managed to find them in Argentina after the war
To build a second existence under a false name,
however, he was
tracked down by the Israeli secret service by the Mossad,
anesthetized and brought
to Israel on a plane at night and live actions
and he was put on trial in Jerusalem.
Ahrens was a correspondent as a
journalist for the New Yorker, which she
had meanwhile  American
Citizenship She reported
live from this courtroom for the New Yorker
and you must think that the
Eichmann trial received the same
attention worldwide as the
war crimes trials in Nuremberg and
Ben Gurion, the Israeli Prime Minister, had already said in advance that
now we have the monster we will become
Give the monster his just punishment and the public prosecutor
is similar, he said Eichmann
was a pervert, a mentally disturbed
perry hotter and he's
not sitting in the glass box now when you were
afraid that the land would come into play
or was there, but for his own
protection because  The mood
was so high that they put him
in this glass box for his own protection
and Hannah Arendt had a completely different impression right
at the beginning of the trial when the
indictment was read out because it was his
first bled ever that he
was not guilty
says despite the
prosecutor's efforts
everyone could see that this man
was not a monster but it was actually
very difficult to avoid the suspicion
that they were dealing with a buffoon
and Eichmann said he had nothing
against Jews and he was not an anti-Semite  He
was just a good official and
fulfilled all his administrative duties and of course
yes and he said above all that
the indictment was false if
he was accused of murder yes and
he had nothing to do with it at all I
quote above all that  Accusation of
murder false and now Arendt quoted
Eichmann I had
nothing to do with the killing of the Jews I have never
killed a Jew I have never killed anyone at all
I have never given an order to kill
a Jew nor have I given an order
to kill one  - I did
n't do anything to Jews and the
next thing a witness said in court was that he saw
Eichmann kill
a Jewish boy while visiting a concentration camp
and that was the only time in the
trial where Eichmann really freaked out
He always answered everything very calmly and
exactly, but then he got
emotional like he said, that's not true, that's a
lie, he couldn't hurt a fly
and it actually
turned out that he
wasn't there at the time and the system
then had to accept this accusation  Withdraw the murder of the
boy because he
was demonstrably somewhere different than the witness
said that he was there
and that was the problem. Quote: the
prosecution tried again and again to prove at least
one specific murder or manslaughter in vain
and in fact they didn't have a single
person with them  killed by his own hand, he
had four children, no criminal record, a
Christian upbringing, he didn't
kill anyone, but what was he then, what do
you do with someone like that and Hannah
Arendt says he was a completely new type of
perpetrator, he was a desk perpetrator and
she coined the term for him
Administrative mass
murderer Administrative mass murderer
and in fact
Raich only ever reported on his
desk activities how he just
phoned so and so
because he had to
call the Reichsbahn, for example, in occupied Germany and had to say
I had to first find out how
many Jews  to be deported then
he has to request the train wagons and
in some cases they had already
accepted cabaret trains because Eichmann
said he already admits that he
wanted to be a good official when he
got the instructions
to deport the Jews in such and such a country  Do
it so well that no empty
wagons or half-filled wagons are driven because
he would have misused
transport capacities that were important to the war effort, so to speak, and
that was certainly his
ambition, but he wasn't
aware of anyone's guilt. He always said it was
an order and that's why Hannah
Arendt said there wasn't one  depth, that's not
demonic, it's simply the unwillingness to
ever imagine what's actually going on with
the other person and in fact,
I always say yes, well, he
put the people in his department in the train that was then that didn't
interest him because that  was outside
his area of ​​responsibility and
said now and now we are approaching the
banality of evil she says the
disturbing thing about
Eichmann as a person was precisely that he
was like many and that these many
were and are frighteningly normal, that
is also something  Then I have to
think about it again
and the judge almost
went crazy. He always said to him
that they didn't have a bad conscience
and they knew what was happening and
that was what led to it, so he said
he had known about it since at the latest  In 1942,
that the Jews he
deported were sent to extermination camps
because he was at the
Wannsee Conference when the final
solution was decided, but he
said that everyone can read that as a
secretary as a minute taker, he would
never have been able to speak up and make a
decision in question  He was
far too small a cog and if he had
spoken up they would
n't have called him at all, he just
wrote down but he knew but then
the judge said then they must
have a bad conscience now
I have a no  I
always forbade myself to think about the decision of
whether the transport
was fair or unjust because that wasn't
my responsibility. I just had to be
responsible for the transport
taking place on time, so of
course that almost drove everyone crazy,
yes, and in fact he was that kind of guy
Something and thanked and that's why
Hannah Arendt says
it was, so to speak, difficult
thanklessness that predestined you
to become one of the greatest criminals of that
time, that such
unrealistic and thoughtlessness
can cause more harm than all
the evil instincts inherent in people
put together, that was in fact  The
lesson that could be learned in Jerusalem
and Aren's conclusion is that lies
the horror of evil and at the same time its
banality
that he said quite banally yes, how
I received the instruction from the Reich Main Security
Office, yes, and
carried out the instruction as a good thing, but
I  I've never killed a person, that
's the banality of evil and now
it continues but the real
madness is now coming.
In this context, a
specific question was asked as to how he
organized the transport and then
of course they also asked to show that he was
n't  is anti-Semitic and to save his head
he said he worked fantastically with the Jews,
yes, and this chapter of Jewish councils has
become a very hot topic that Hannah
Arendt has touched on in this book,
it has caused an incredible amount of trouble for a
decade and because  The
problem was she
dedicated a large chapter to it and also researched it herself
and Jewish councils that have a little
backstory. Heidrich decreed in 1939
that every ghetto, every Jewish community,
every Jewish settlement needs a
Jewish council, which is either the rabbi
or a very high-ranking person  Respected
personality of the community, namely
so that the Nazis had a contact person
and so in the entire
Jewish community, in addition to the rabbi
or a high-ranking personality, they were
selected who then
took over this cooperation. In the first few years,
the Jewish councils only had to
carry out smaller tasks, write lists about
The residents have
names etc. as usual based on their age, but also
distribute the Jewish stars and ensure
that all Jews have stars, but since
1942 at the latest, these Jews have had
councils, which, by the way, are in all countries.
Then there was massive destruction in all occupied countries,
one has to say
of her own people
and that was of course a message that
was bitter to no end and I
told you so, she didn't
look away, says I want to understand and
that's why I brought you this
longer quote back then. She says this
role of the Jewish leaders in the
For Jews, destruction of their own people is
undoubtedly the darkest chapter
in the entire dark history. In
Amsterdam as in Warsaw, in Berlin as
in Budapest, the Nazis could
rely on Jewish officials to
produce lists of personnel and assets to cover the costs of
deportation and extermination
So they had to
pay for their own train fare
as the cost of the deportation and
extermination because the people to be deported would be
kept an eye on the apartments that had become vacant and police forces
would be available to seize the Jews
and bring them onto the trains  To
help until the bitter end, there were
actually Jewish police in many Jewish
settlements and ghettos
who worked for the Jewish council,
who then often
made the arrests and even when
they hid Jews who were looking for them
and bringing them to the train stations
And there are
also statements that Hannah Arendt
also quotes that some Jews on their
way to the concentration camps
only saw Jews and not a
single German and that is of course
tragic, yes and that is why it comes to
the conclusion that if the Jewish
people had been leaderless, the
total number would have been  The number of victims hardly reached the number
of four and a half to six million
people
and she says under certain circumstances even
one in two could have survived because without
the address lists with age,
gender and information, without these
exact lists and without these total
assistants, the Jewish councils will join the Nazis
The search for the Jews
was complete chaos, yes, and they
would have had to withdraw a lot of forces from the
front to first
search through everything, see how he lived,
where he lived in Vienna, etc. and to arrest them all and bring them
all to the train stations
There are millions of people
and the whole thing could never have happened
if the Jewish councils
hadn't cooperated and the whole thing came to a
head again in the courtroom when
one of these Jewish councils
was supposed to testify against Eichmann, so
they actually brought him in as a prosecution witness.
It was
him  hammer according to what he was called it was the
pinchas joyful jew council of budapest
who also worked with eichmann
and gave teichmann the
lists of the budapest jews and
when they entered the courtroom
he was insulted as a murderer as well as
jewish and in hungarian world people
were serving  A striking one because
they had lost relatives and
joyer hadn't told the Jews
that they were going to extermination camps,
even though they knew that for sure and didn't say anything.
He simply had them brought to the train station with the appropriate forces. If he had told them,
of course we didn't have the people
like lying went to the train station but
fled and
the quote from Arendt now writes
describes what was going on in the courtroom because
she says more joyfully an orthodox Jew
was violently excited. Here there are people who
say that no one advised them to
flee but from the people who fled
50 percent were
caught again and killed and he could
n't have reconciled with his conscience
telling people that flies will kill
you if you go to the train station
and then 50 percent are caught and
killed. Hannah Arendt doesn't accept that,
she says 99 percent are against it
fatalities among those who did not
try to escape and he would
probably have had to say it, yes
and ultimately she says it more happily and
other Jewish councils and rabbis who all
cooperated with the Nazis
show Arendt and now comes a
blatant quote about the totality of
morality  collapse that the Nazis
caused in all layers of society throughout Europe, not only
among the persecutors but also among
the persecuted and that is of course a
hard quote that you can say that the
Nazis caused the totality of moral
collapse not only
among the persecutors as well as among them  you man
who had a total moral
collapse here, the German did his
duty, who gave his instructions to
war, but not only
among the persecutors but also among the
persecuted, namely among the Jews there was
this collapse because the
Jews also cooperated
and did legal things  They did what they were told, yes,
and
that triggered an enormous storm of
indignation.
So you can't imagine that Hannah
Arendt, when she
came back from her trip to Europe, didn't
realize what she
had done for the first time. There were thousands of
letters with death threats and
insults against
her  She would have betrayed her own people. She would have
given the anti-Semites arguments. She would have
also used the title "the banality of
evil." She would have declared the Holocaust as banal,
which of course is nonsense. She would
n't have declared the Holocaust as banal
and wanted to insult the victims. I
said that it was happening  could have
reasons and where you look closely is
the banal fulfillment of duty by officials
who gave up their conscience, so to speak,
before they went to work
but she was insulted incredibly and
she even bruno jonas i.e. philosopher
jonas and others who stood again
said she was getting ready  Gone
and
the person close to her, her
stepfather, no longer spoke to her
and the
historian Golem, who was close to her and whom she already
knew as France,
had to earn money after going to France.
She was in exile with him and then wrote a letter
where he said  He
no longer understands whether she
doesn't love her own people enough and now
Ari's answer corresponds
to itself again. She says, firstly, I have never
loved any people or collective in my life. I actually
only love my friends.
Secondly, it would be  I love the
Jews because I'm Jewish myself, I'm suspicious,
I don't love myself and that's
crazy, you know, after that she
took part and she stuck to her
thesis because she simply said I
want to understand and she also writes that she
has it there  She was touched by an incredibly repressed
chapter of Jewish history
and she then found herself the victim
of a smear campaign by the Jewish
establishment because there were a lot of Jewish
councils. The Jewish councils survived almost all of the
things because of their cooperation
She said that she fears that's
why this smear campaign is coming.
It's only about one thing and it's the
truth and she was simply an extremely
strong personality. She also
criticized the state of Israel because of the mass
expulsion of 850,000 Arabs and because of
individual massacres of Arabs that
hit her  But she also criticized Adenauer and
the German government
because of this completely
inadequate persecution of former
Nazi
employees and potentates. Yes, she
also criticized the American
government and the USA because of the
Vietnam War and the Soviet Union because of
the suppression of the Hungarian
uprising. So she always did  If she was what she was,
her flag was raised and
the historians criticized her
objectively only on one point. She
said yes, half of the Jews would have
survived if the Jews had not cooperated.
The historians said
the number was probably too high, but
Hannah Arendt stuck with it. Yes, she said, it
's important that we look, even
if it's a dark chapter, but we have
to realize that Jews also had a
moral collapse and
simply followed their instructions and their
duty as Jewish councilors for the Nazis, just
like they do
It made a difference
then said well, you ca
n't lump Eichmann and the Jewish councilors together.
One of them was an
active perpetrator for the Nazis, the
Jewish councilors did it under duress,
so it's completely clear that was terrible for them
Well, you can't
lump it together, but what's actually happening is
she says we have to look,
yes, I believe that we
can only come to terms with this past
if we start to judge, and
strongly, and judging and judging
also includes the 1  The
insight into the banality of the evil Iago
was also Eichmann was not Iago and not
Macbeth. Apart from a very unusual
eagerness to do everything that would help his
advancement, he has no motives at all
and there too it was criticized because
newer research has shown that
Eichmann in his  Exile in Argentina
gave an interview to a neo-Nazi who wasn't a neo-Nazi but to a Dutch SS man who had survived,
where Eichmann made quite anti-Semitic
comments and I think
probably or I would say
pretty sure Eichmann was already
anti-Semitic but nonetheless the
thesis is  Correct, I think the thesis
is still correct and Jaspers,
who was also a
lifelong friend of Arendt,
was the only one who said that this
is a declaration of totalitarianism
from which we can really learn something
because what has been taking place in the Federal Republic so far and
demonization doesn't
help either  Years ago, they say that
demonization itself serves as an alibi,
so it lies with the person in the flesh and as a
result, you are not
to blame at all and in fact, perhaps
you still remember the
school lessons, I experienced this
at high school and even when I
studied history  If it went in that
direction the Germans were all very
good democrats like today then came
the luzie free form of Hitler and
Hitler's helpers and the whole satan
then evil came to earth and
Goebbels fought off
all the good democrats with cunning propaganda
seduced and that's how it could happen
but that falls short, this
demonization only serves as an
excuse and he doesn't
accept that.
She doesn't say anything like that. Eichmann wasn't a
Lucifer of the AP on the day and then she says
from a meaning and senseless
existence in the world  The wind is currently
chosen to be the center of the story, yes,
and
he would probably never have
committed any evil deeds otherwise he would have
been, as I said, very
fond of children, Christian education,
went to church, no criminal record, he
would probably have spent his
whole life not being conspicuous,
would not have liked him  Hannah
Arendt says the wind of history is
chosen to be in the center and there he says
in the end he always came out with the fact
that he
simply carried out the instructions,
but that doesn't apply, yes and now here comes Hannah
Arendt definitely said that
I'm guilty, yes  He didn't say he
was innocent, no matter how banal his
activities were, but on the contrary,
as an administrative mass murderer, he was
guilty because he said he
was always just and that's
not possible, he says and refers to Kant. No
one has the right to do justice to Kant
none of us have the right to
just serve, we are always
people too, not just civil servants and
not just soldiers and
basically he shouldn't have organized the transports
after he knew
where these people were being transported to and
she says the death sentence was therefore
right and she  If you say that you
should have told him the following if you refer
to obedience, we would like to
remind you that in the political
sphere of adults the word
obedience is just another word for
approval and support, yes
and now we are
nowhere near your actual core idea
has the right to suffice
and only if we recognize this banality of
evil that is connected to this immediate
obedience can
we also answer the three big questions of German
history: why did
the proud Prussian officer,
with their long tradition,
despise Hitler from the beginning  As a
Bohemian corporal who was militarily
clueless as long as
he was held steady and in 1944, when
everything was really going to hell, he
dared to do something against him.
The second question is why did
tens of thousands of civil servants, police officers and even
judges actively participate in the spirit of the National Socialists
And the third question is
why and over 90 million
Reich Germans
civil society why
couldn't civil society resist anymore with a few exceptions like
Sophie Scholl or Georg Elser the
craftsman it's actually crazy
and we have to answer the questions
we have to look closely
and them  says that we live
in a mass society today,
we are also uprooted, we are
interchangeable and that is why it is
a danger to our democracy today
and that is exactly why we have to
look closely, yes, because following
institutional instructions is also
a problem today, yes  and she calls it
the rule of no one, the
rule of no one is the actual
form of government, the bureaucracy, that is
also part of the banality of evil and the
bureaucracy, this line that is there
makes you aware of this trend line to
emphasize bureaucratius kratos is
Greek and means the rule  and
so how do they say the rule of the
office
and
yes and she says
the rule of the office we get used
to the fact that we
carry out all the orders you know we vote
every four years these days but the
ministries that remain completely
march on there will only be the
minister and  the state secretaries
replaced otherwise this
bureaucracy remains and we have to be critical there too,
yes and
she says and although there is no
collective guilt of the Germans she says
that Eichmann was like many and that was
the frightening thing about him but
they are still a collective guilt of the Germans
and says  You really have to
look closely in each individual case at what
the person could have done, what would have been
possible and what not, but
of course we also have to ask the question
why so many citizens, officials,
police, judges, actively participated,
yes, and afterwards they all
said the same thing  said quote
Arendt over and over again
they asserted that they had never done anything on their own initiative,
they had no
good or bad
intentions of any kind but always just
followed orders, yes and in this
context she says that is the hardness
of submission to the rule
of obeying nobody's
orders and orders
that is the banality of evil and
of course it exists everywhere but the
Germans are characterized by something
special. Quote I don't
think that the German people
are particularly brutal. What seems specifically German to me
is this  crazy
idealization of obedience you know
with the ss people it was upside down
lock your honor means loyalty so they
even raised this motto to their
highest ideal the
Wehrmacht soldiers also had to swear on the person of
adolf hitler they didn't
swear to defend the fatherland
but so to speak
adolf hitler
to carry out orders immediately yes yes they didn't rely on
hitler and that's why just because
obedience
was held so high, so to speak, in the third empire it was
perhaps possible that the
officer corps stood by hitler for so long and there
was so little resistance
but that's it  That's the problem, this
damn obedience and she says only a
child is fair, but that has to be
taken into account when the mother says it's
red, stops immediately, yes then I have to
stay away, if it keeps running, it's
driven away and the car comes, yes,
but she also says obey  This is what
we do as long as we are children,
so it is necessary, but the matter
should come to an end by the age of 14 or 15
at the latest. At
puberty at the latest, you have to start
taking responsibility yourself
and you have to ask yourself whether my
actions are right or wrong
And she says that applies to everyone, including
soldiers, who are not allowed to
rely on obedience. Quote: there's something outrageously stupid about the appeal to old age and the fact that
responsibility has been taken away from you,
and
also the justification of millions of
Germans. Well, Hahn didn't think all of that was
good, but you've got it  not
being able to do anything doesn't
really apply, because she says there was an
alternative and that meant not taking part,
judging for yourself,
yes, and she says you don't have to
risk your life right away, you can't
ask everyone to do that, yes, but there's a
whole range of options  Resistance that was
possible was sometimes also practiced
in individual cases. You could
call in sick. You could delay things massively. You could
act stupid. You
could
do all sorts of things to
make things go awry. You didn't have to immediately
or you could also
help Jews and say something  Then who should you turn to
if you didn't
dare to hide yourself,
so there was a whole range
and she says what was important was just
judging for yourself, please, I won't do that, I wo
n't put my life at risk, I'm
trying to escape, I'm trying like
I am  I'm coming around the other corner but I'm
not joining in, yes and she just
said
the problem is that many people
haven't thought about what
form of resistance they can offer. For
example, the Reichsbahn
members, the train drivers, they've
noticed everything, they've done that
Yes, there were thousands of them and they were
later questioned and they then
said yes,
I'm a train driver, yes, what did they want from me, I
'm a train driver, we went to the
service building behind it, the roster then
it said 830 seven wagons Auschwitz for
I'm a train driver, you understand that
the banality of evil and
that's why Arendt says the greatest
evil committed is the evil that was done by no one,
that is, by human
beings who refuse to be people,
so that's it and that's the point.
Now of course the question for our
democracy today is  Do we continue today
or are we still just as cautious and
subservient to the authorities and many say the
generation of our grandparents because we
were brought up in such an authoritarian way,
of course they
stood still and were enough. Today
it would be completely different, but ladies
and gentlemen that  Milgram experiment
by the American psychologist
Milligram unfortunately teaches us something
better.
I brought this to you once.
Stanley Milgram.
He
recruited 40 test subjects at the university
for an experiment and
told them that the experiment is all
about us examining a student's ability to learn
We try to
get them to perform better through small punishments or through punishments with electric shocks
and then let the draw be drawn. The
student is again the test person,
but that
was the case  There were 41
people in one of the students and then he
sat down the students were
tied to an electric chair and let
the people shock the student
and the student only has to
put simple words together e.g. house and
tourism on the front door but
also had other values  If you have more
front doors then you just have to
make a front door and every time you made a mistake you got
a 15 volt electric shock
and the next time you made a mistake it was increased by 15
volts and all of the test subjects got
45 volts themselves and the
teachers were worried about it because of this  It's
really painful for them to see what they're
doing, so they already knew what they were
doing and now their
result has actually
shocked Wegrand himself but also the entire professional world and the public and to this day the experiment
has been repeated several times with the same
result  I brought it to you
there were 40 test subjects and 26 were
tortured up to 450 volts yes and if you
think about it now at 100 5
volts he groaned yes then at 120
volts he screamed loudly the
student but they continued to increase yes
then at  150 wanted to, he said do
n't cut me off, let me go, I want to get
out of here and then the
scientist the scientist,
by the way, always stood there next to the white
coat or I think he had the gray
hand even stood next to him as a
scientist and experimenter and
then always when someone  he said he
writes yes that's what the scientist
said whether the student likes it or
not you have to continue yes or
the experiment requires you to
continue. By the way, it was always the
same four sentences that he told everyone
so that the whole thing can be compared
because we have them  The
same students were tortured one after the other or
here, for example, there he has already written that
the blood in his veins freezes. It
was really a heartbreaking
writer after the blow and there
you can see that no one has
gotten out yet and only then did it
happen again  said he can
always answer hand, yes there were 5 people who
got out and when he felt like they were there again, then there
was no more reaction then
one of them said he had
become unconscious, we killed him and then he did  The
experimenter said again that I
take responsibility for everything that
happens. Then they
turned it up a notch, so four of them
got out, but here
two more got out, one in each case that kept
on exhibiting and that was
of course really scary for them because the
students didn't come anymore  did
n't know he's unconscious is he dead what's wrong
with him yes they didn't know and
now comes the madness 26 so the
majority of these 40 have increased increased increased up to the end
so you see the
obedience is still there today as soon as someone
else does  Authority takes over
whether the Reich Security Main Office is like
Reichmann, whether this is the
scientist,
instructions are given as soon as someone says
I take responsibility, the
others are out and afterwards many of
these participants said that it was
quite terrible for them and that they
should have done with their private life  certain
Disney can agree
to give these electric shocks that they
only did against the scientist
and theirs is
the trend exactly that is the banality
of the evil back then she again and she says
for example the author Kaiser of the Nazi
Gauleiter the waiting house that you have after
that  War in Poland also brought to trial,
for example, he
said exactly that in his defense,
he said quote, so everyone quotes
him here in Amman Jerusalem, he
said his official soul, the
official soul of this Gauleiter of the
Vatican, carried out the crimes in
his private life  The soul has
been against it, yes, you understand and
he says in this indifference represents
morally and politically I have the
quote with him this indifference represents
the greatest danger morally and politically. This is where
the horror of
evil lies at the same time its banality and that
is now the  In conclusion, Arendt's very central
message:
We must never, so to speak, disconnect our conscience, our
private soul, our
feelings from our actions, our
official actions, in our
actions, not even when it is ordered,
not even when a scientist is there,
not even when there is some authority
or the government  There is no one
telling us that we always have to think for ourselves
and we must not prescribe any ideology or
orders to ourselves, not even in a
democratic state. She
also said that democratic states wage
wars and gives examples where one
would have to resist democratic states. Yes, and she says ultimately
we all need them  demands from
all of us what she
has always demanded of herself, a way of thinking without railings
and that means we have to come into harmony
with ourselves and
she refers again to Plato's records, says that the
truth in
decisions is to be won through the
conversation of the soul  yourself and
the soul so this in
self-talk because the soul can make contact with
the timeless ideas of the true good
beautiful and then
consider whether what we do was good
and beautiful Arendt has a world of
philosophy and not a metaphysical one, she
says  Ultimately, this self-talk,
this harmony with ourselves that we
create in our thinking, is nothing other than
the mind's conversation with itself
and we also have to stand by this conversation
and that's why she says the wind of
thinking is the ability to be right and
wrong, beautiful and ugly
difference and this can actually
prevent disasters, thank you very much
[applause]